let's be honest at the very least the
doctors the kind of food who knows where
his towel is happy towel day everybody
if you're watching this video and don't
know what that is well it has to do with
the Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
originally a radio play then also a
novel a video game movie all originating
from the mind of Douglas Adams and one
of the major recurring things in it is
that a towel is the single most useful
creation in the entire universe and so
the fans of Hitchhiker's Guide and of
Douglas Adams in general celebrate towel
day now I last year I did a video basis
just talking about my love of
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy because
I do love it I'd love the novels most
specifically and one of my most
treasured possessions is that I have the
audio version of all five original books
written by Douglas Adams narrated by him
it seems like a lot of the audiobooks
you find these alright it may be easier
now that everything's gone digital but
definitely for a while if you wanted
them on CD there was a chunk of time
where all you could get were ones read
by other people and they were fine but
Douglas Adams reading his own work was
phenomenal
anyway I talked about that last year
this year I want to address something
that it has kind of been at the back of
my mind to do a video on is the
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy in the
same universe as Doctor Who that might
make you go I'm sorry
what but those of you who know both
properties might start going oh I wonder
so I'm gonna talk about some of the
things that indicate maybe yes some of
the things that indicate maybe no first
let's talk about the obvious connection
douglas adams was a script editor on a
Doctor Who
and actually one of the books in the
series which is life the universe and
everything the third book that was a
repurposed script proposal he had for
dr. who called Doctor Who and the
cricket men and he repurposed the basics
of that story into an actual
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy book so
aside from the fact that one is entirely
his creation and the other one he worked
on and in addition to that he rose city
of death he wrote sha de which didn't
get fully produced at the time but now
has a wonderful animated recreation and
all those things it there are obvious
links but there are let's talk not meta
links not links of the creator to the
works let's talk about actual in
universe are there things that connect
them and indicate maybe this all goes on
in the same place well yeah there's a
number of things let's start with kind
of a big one Arthur Dent the lead
character of Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy gets named dropped by David
Tennant by the Tenth Doctor his exact
words are and this is during the
Christmas invasion so tenants very first
story that he's in he talks about how he
just saved the world in his
dressing-gown very Arthur Dent oh there
was a nice man now here's the thing you
might think ah it's a pop culture
reference he has other ones in this very
episode he does a Lion King referenced
earlier yeah but what a nice man that's
not something you say about a fictional
character that's something you say about
somebody you've met and that would seem
to indicate that the doctor has met
Arthur Phillip dead so there's your
first thing but that's not a lot to go
off of
sounds like just a nod okay whatever
well I got more in the Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy books there is a
character who actually does not appear
in the books but is reference repeatedly
named lunk eluphant
who's known for writing
very well selling philosophical books
you know about God and the nature of the
universe and the creation of everything
and you know what happens in destiny of
the Daleks which yes was done when
Douglas Adams was it was script editor
over on classic who there's a point
where the doctor is pinned he pulls a
book out of his pocket starts reading it
and it's a book by Rulon khalifat and he
starts it going huh got it wrong on the
very first page so we now have our third
dent being referenced as if he's a real
person and books from an author who is
an author in the Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy universe appearing in both
okay one could be nothing to that could
still be coincidence right Wow let's
talk about something that's a little bit
of a less direct reference and let's
talk about something conceptual because
there's something that exists in the
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy that
bears a pretty strong resemblance to
something that exists in Doctor Who so
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
introduced in the third book that's life
the universe and everything has what's
called the somebody else's problem field
it basically creates a mental blind spot
where people will look at a thing and
their brain will interpret it as being
somebody else's problem and therefore
not worth thinking about rendering it
effectively invisible but not really you
can't look at it but only if you know
what it is or maybe if you're very lucky
to catch it out of the corner of your
eye
what does that sound like perhaps how
about a perception filter the idea of
the eyes just kind of sliding off
something unless you're really
concentrating and you know it's their
perception filters have come up a few
times in Doctor Who different name
perception filters somebody else's
problem field this one obviously had
being a little bit cheeky err with the
way it describes the technology but
that seems pretty close doesn't it I've
also got another very direct reference
recently am i rewatch of going through
the modern era of Doctor Who I got two
rings of Akutan and in rings of Akutan
there is a reference to an alien species
initially seen and heard him referenced
in Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy and
that's a hula boo now and in rings of
Akutan all that we get is the doctor
saying to Clara
Oh a hula vu we don't see it but also I
don't think we could given what who who
is a hula boo is a hyper-intelligent
shade of the color blue so good luck
creating that visually in a way that
would make any kind of sense so makes
total sense that it would be off-screen
and they wouldn't actually show that to
us but that is absolutely what he calls
out by name hmm this one's a little bit
more of a parallel thing than a direct
reference but I kind of want to mention
this anyways
so in Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
again introduced in life universe and
everything huh funny how many of these
things are coming up tied to the story
that originated as a doctor who plot hmm
anyways there is a spaceship called the
starship Bistro math this is actually
one of my favorite things in the entire
series the way this ship works I'm not
gonna go into it right now but is this
wonderfully bizarre take on mathematics
but that's not what ties it into Doctor
Who it is a space traveling ship capable
of traveling vast distances and an
immense speeds and just be it's a real
mover of a ship it can go almost
anywhere and it looks like an Italian
bistro so imagine an Italian bistro just
flying through space that would be as
ridiculous as a diner
flying through space like the one Clara
flew off in at the end of hell-bent not
so unique anymore hmm
now is there anything that would be a
little bit more definitively well
because of this they can't take place in
the same universe yeah it seems to be
and that's the fact that the very first
notable thing that happens in the
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy is that
the earth gets demolished and in Doctor
Who the earth is demonstrably not
demolished it's threatened every other
freaking week but it's still there it
has very clearly not been destroyed by
the Vogons to make way for a bite for a
hyperspace bypass so that should be the
end of that shouldn't it actually no now
doctor who has been fairly squirrely and
cautious about how it is approached the
idea of a multiverse and things like
parallel universes it's been in there a
little bit but it there's also been a
lot of emphasis on how that's not
supposed to happen and travel between
parallel dimensions is not supposed to
happen but there is an acknowledgment
that they exist and we also have in
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy an
acknowledgment of parallel multiple
universes because even after the earth
is destroyed Arthur does land on it
again it's not quite the same earth he
left it's different he's somewhere else
but he didn't find it again and then
actually went on to find it yet again
and depending on whether or not you
consider the sixth book to be canon
which I do that brings even more layers
into it there are potentially infinite
numbers of versions of Earth but more
importantly
Arthur has bounced between a few of them
so even if the parallel universe he
originated from the earth was destroyed
that doesn't mean that the doctor
couldn't meet him at some point after
he'd hopped over to another one so if we
say that the earth destroyed in the
original book Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy call that hitchhiker prime earth
if the doctor ran into Arthur at
whatever point he transitioned in over
to the the earth that he lands on in so
long and thanks for all the fish called
that hitchhiker Fenchurch earth if
you're out the books you know why I call
it that then it's totally viable that
earth is still there and our third egg
came from an earth that was destroyed
and he would have had the possibility of
bumping into the doctor cuz he did a lot
of bumming around before landing on that
earth again do they take place in the
same universe I think they just might
what do you think though whatever your
thoughts are drop something on down in
the comments let's talk about it all the
stuff to do you know what it is like
subscribe share this video around share
the love support me on patreon maybe
whatever you feel like doing though no
pressure though you're a bunch of Hoopoe
fruits you can figure it out for
yourself
end of the day you're the council and
I'm just running the meetings until next
time don't panic
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]